i went through a really hard stage of my
life and it was because i was dealing
with my
sexuality it was self-identity it was
being an adoptee trying to figure out
who i was what i wanted to be
and the expectations that i felt like i
needed to uphold
this is great i'm gonna talk forever
about this now let me ask you this
so when did it start these feelings of
like you know
who am i i think you know what i mean
sexually
rebelling all that stuff when did that
happen as
i think it was always in me and then i
didn't realize it
until i could understand what it what it
meant
yeah so 14 earlier
12. i knew i was gay i knew like i knew
i could feel it inside of me
like i don't know when when do you go
through puberty
how old are you six seven eight twelve
no as early as nine even
there were like you i could tell right i
was looking at things differently
not in a sexual way as like my sexuality
but just like feeling like oh my god
who am i and what i what am i doing um
so with those with those feelings inside
did you get straight a's
no you seem like you got straight a's
i i did in music art
creative creative stuff yeah math
science i nearly
failed math and science we're the same i
think
thank you god we're the same lord we
refer to him the lord lord hear
you and i are the same kind of korean
or people no we're just people
i know korean okay okay no i'm gonna i'm
gonna specialize it
oh gotcha specialized yeah let me
specialize it okay
i just because growing up
my parents always told me that like
accordions
you know they get ready they go to
harvard you know
that kind of thing and then as i get
older i meet people like
kristen and david cho and these types of
people that are
like-minded like we have the same kind
of like
you know struggles and whatnot and it's
like
we're all so creative in different you
know
in different ways and it just it feels
you know
like i'm not alone almost but did your
parents allow you to
water that creative grass they let me
mess up
yeah that's a difference that's where
you
when you were in high school and do you
smoking pot
no drugs not in high school cigarettes
cigarettes did you drink in high school
i pretended to
what drink yeah i didn't enjoy it but i
liked it did you
date guys just for the optics of it
uh high school no because i didn't
really like yes i was like let's get a
boyfriend like because that's what
you're supposed to do yeah but
i didn't not because i wanted to live my
life
as like a true partner to a man right
you know what i mean
the title of it is what you were going
did you go to prom or homecoming or that
of course yeah
yeah with with men right boy i should
call them boys
did you go to college then i went to my
first year of college for international
business and economics
i was nearly failing out of it i was
doing horribly it was
awful and then my mom was like you're
not going back why don't you try
culinary school you love cooking we'll
get you out of michigan
we'll go to chicago we'll get you set up
and go do you
oh that's a good mom great mom yeah
that's a great mom
and then you were like yes so when did
the sexuality when did you come out
i came out at 2
7 8. wow wow was it 28
i don't know yeah i know that's like
google everywhere
she came out i think he was 28 i think
it was 28 28. but i was already dating
women but here's the thing also my life
was never public until after top chef
which i never really
understood what it looked like to have
like a public person
how old were you when top chef happened
i
2014. to whole are you i don't know
i don't know we've all failed i failed
at math i can't yeah
yeah george yeah yeah wait wait were you
out by the time you were on top shelf
no i came out after top shelf oh but you
you were you already knew who you were
you were 31. thank you
yeah it took me a while yeah we got
there right so that's
that's interesting i was 31 when i was
on top 30 or 31. no i
no it was before that okay well you said
25. i'm done right
seven years ago and you're 38 now 37.
okay you were 30 you were 30. you were
29. you competed in 2012.
i competed hey you have no one [ __ ]
year do
yeah yeah yeah anyway it doesn't matter
did your mom know though when you before
you came out
did you let me tell you how i came out
to my mom so i started dating someone
and that's why i decided to come out
because i was like
[ __ ] this i don't want to live in like
private i actually love i'm i felt i
fell in love with someone and so i
remember i was sitting in my apartment
i was laying on my bed with my phone
looking at the ceiling and i was like
mom
she's like yeah i was like i gotta tell
you something and like
what felt like i don't know eternity
nothing was coming out and i was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was like i'm dating someone she's
like okay
and i said we're gonna come home
she's like okay and i was like and it's
a girl
and like what felt like she didn't say
anything forever
she was like oh well i think we already
knew kristen are you happy
and i said yes she was like great can't
wait to meet her
that's it it's so sweet yeah that was it
it's sweet the movie yeah yeah it moved
me because um
my parents would have done that mm-hmm i
certainly wouldn't shall we please
because the expectation that they wanted
for you you wouldn't replay it
okay dad yeah
so if you had told your dad that you had
you know um
um lovers
male lovers when you were in high school
how would he have taken it oh he knew
oh he did oh well he knew that i i
sucked dick before
yeah yeah they're not lovers oh i don't
wait how do you say that to your dad
yeah i would rather call him a boyfriend
no no
i go you know i just said hey when in
high school and where i was young in
middle school
i sucked a couple of people's penises
and what did he say
well this isn't like when i was in rehab
right so you know
he i mean he he laughed when i said that
i was molested by a guy with down
syndrome
are you serious oh in group yeah he went
into
home my whole family the whole family oh
my god yeah
and um then everyone in the group
laughed you know i mean it became a
thing and i was like
that was hilarious right but
yeah my parents knew because of the
massive
methamphetamine and drugs and all the
stuff that i was doing that they just
thought i was gonna die
so you know at that point they saw me
having no future right they're like this
guy
can die like this guy has no skill set
he's something happened at birth i i
don't know what they were thinking
but they were like obviously i mean i
went to three rehabs
in high school and they just kept
shelling out this money and they're like
putting me in these places i'm in these
you know these hospital gowns constantly
and um then in my when i got did get
sober
i lived at home for years like the way i
behaved now i sleep until three
late at night jerk off you know i mean
frantically you know and just had no
future
yeah you know and then i became a star
wait can i can i can i ask you a
question yeah and i don't know forgive
me if um
you've probably talked about this a
million times or maybe you don't want to
talk about it at all
go ahead um you know when
you started experimenting with drugs and
when it became like an issue and it
would ever
became an addiction do you have you
pinpointed